we're gonna do a new level of
rollercoaster tycoon
today the natural progression in the
roller coaster tycoon universe is to go
to dynamite [ __ ] June's [ __ ]
yes look we already have a bunch of
[ __ ] and hoes in here look at them
stupid stupid stupid [ __ ] and we
have this [ __ ] roller coaster
this is a really problematic roller
coaster cuz like it's so cool and you
know you can never build anything cooler
than it but it never makes that much
money
look at all these [ __ ] leaving my
park well guess what that's a no exit
now idiots
your tracked your alter at love the
minions in my domain [ __ ]
always hated this stupid hill as well
this hill ruined my life just you just
couldn't bill anything stupid why should
we start building what are you bursting
alright someone said carousel
great idea where should we build it I
don't know there's so many questions in
life and I don't know if I'm ready to
answer them
that [ __ ] just puked where is he
where is it
Oh what is he thinking I feel sick
yeah well you know what we did is sick
people
hey guys we're doing great so far I'm
really proud of you bros you're really
helping out here it's it's a really
great experience I think it really
reminds me of when I was young in it and
wild you know and I'm saying you don't
know what I'm saying well I don't know
what to tell you then Jesus Christ
I need more names all right so give me
German names that I can name the rides
cuz otherwise uh no fun allowed all
right there we go
dude pretty good so far I'm pretty proud
of myself you bros not so much you bros
have done nothing for me you're all dead
to me
someone said don't lon great name great
name
that's the carousel uncie organ ha ha ha
ok
this will be the house uragan very good
hey I'm not gonna call the slide Hitler
all right Jesus Christ this is like the
first time we really properly hang out
and I just just realize you're old
you're all sick [ __ ] Gunther
you know what I can go with Gunther
great thank you
Bam Bam Bam I am ok let's let's do this
no not the whole Oh coaster stop stop
there we go this is pretty good this is
a pretty tight little roller coaster the
everyone just keeps saying holy coaster
you know what fine I didn't make the
joke it's a good joke no it's not it's
offensive I don't like it all right here
we go
we did it BAM the Halle coaster is
complete for the nest mother line they
can't find the entrance to Gunther that
sounds kinky we sorta Kunta oh [ __ ]
you're right Bros why didn't you tell me
Gunther doesn't have an entrance how
will people get inside Gunther if
there's no entrance [ __ ] sake is no
one going on my [ __ ] roller coat the
Halle coaster oh [ __ ] the Halle coaster
alright that was a bad idea
let's pill this this is the true and
real
roller coaster and nothing else all
right yeah look at this and we can make
it go down and [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
look at that do you see are you looking
look at it just look at it oh my god
look at these are so expensive I'm
losing all my money on this gross are
you even oh my god I'm trying to teach
you a lesson about life here the [ __ ]
are you doing there we go this is pretty
cool
look at it did I blow my budget No BAM
open open and ready for business the
penetrating coaster yeah that's that's
blurry climber right there look at it
it's so smooth it's such a joy ride look
at it it's free how can you say no you
know what I just got a crazy idea it's
so crazy that it might actually work
this is gonna be the sickest dopest [ __ ]
you've ever [ __ ] [ __ ] look at that
that's pretty cool I bet you're thinking
right now like how the [ __ ] does he come
up with a [ __ ] I'm so turned on right
now
look at this this is gonna be the dopest
oh my god it comes up it comes up Bruce
it's [ __ ] comes up look at that I
would go in this if you want oh my god
oh my god him it's um I'm offended okay
look at this and then Bam Bam Bam yes
yes and then it's just gonna go like
this that's a pretty terrible and then
down whoa dude that's pretty dope that's
pretty fresh yo yeah we're gonna be rich
pros we're gonna be so rich on bushland
we're gonna be so rich look at it open
open for business they better go on this
[ __ ] they better [ __ ] go I swear to
God what happened with the roller
coaster oh god no it's not working
no dammit they're going on the roller
coaster they're gonna die oh no oh no oh
no they don't know they don't know what
we know oh [ __ ] it's going oh god oh god
they all died
oh god no the kids right everyone just
died God so I don't understand the
problem like people died what where I
don't what diet people can die or eat
what are you so you can't no you're
kidding with me no there's no way no way
man you be crazy man no no one ever died
in our Park they love this one too they
love it they love it they love they
don't really love that one actually they
love it alright pres thank you so much
for joining this stream it's been a
pleasure you bros are really weird and I
appreciate that you know what I think
weird appreciate comes too weird and I
accept it's that I'm trying to end this
on a good note but it's really hard cuz
okay um I first see in the next video as
always stay awesome press and one of
your bros ideas was anytime someone does
something bad I'll just drown them
I'll just drive